[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Maggy Friedman je
suis apiculteur professionnel gérant de
l'erla fils run et producteur de miel de
la réunion des mial rares comme des
miels connus
je travaille en agriculture biologique
on a des collaborations avec le quart de
parc national ce qui nous permet d'aller
chercher des miels rares type fameux
Miel Vert en rouge mais également
maintenant le mien de fleur jaune ou des
mials de jouvence et de Mao qui sont des
petites perles de notre île et bien
évidemment on a des miens unique au
monde
enfin ma spécialité finalement le miel
crémeux qui est un miel cristallisé mais
onctueux et tartinable c'est vraiment ce
qui pour moi caractérise des sens du
miel amial à la fois agréable à
travailler et
exceptionnel en bouche
l'année dernière on a été l'horaire
d'une médaille d'argent sur le miel de
Lecci
ayant du coup cette année on a décidé de
voir un peu plus loin et de présenter
nos produits on national et
international afin de le faire connaître
le valoriser et
d'ouvrir de nouveaux marchés pour la
filière locale
[Musique]